[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبداها بابرس العناوين
بغداد تنجذب بالهجمات الايرانيه والتركيه
على اقليم كردستان وترفض تصفيه الحسابات
على ارضها
وزير الطاقه السعوديه في تقارير عن زياده
الانتاجي بمقدار 500000 برميل يوميا ويؤكد
استمرار التخفيض حتى 2023
[تصفيق]
صدى الاحتجاجات يصل الى المونديال لاعبوا
المنتخب الايراني يرفضون ترديد نشيد
بلادهم ويتلقون سته اهداف من انجلترا
في اندونيسيا ارتفاع وحصيره الزلزال الى
162 قتيلا ومخاوف من وجود العشرات تحت
الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه على ان
الهجمات التركيه والايرانيه بالمسيرات
والصواريخ التي استهدفت اقليم كردستان
العراق تخالف المواثيق الدوليه وتعد خرقا
لسياده العراق كما عبرت عن رفضها على ان
تكون الاراضي العراقيه ساحه لتصفيه
الحسابات لاطراف خارجيه مشدده على الا
تكون اراضي العراق مقرا او ممرنا لالحاق
الضرر والاذى باي من دول الجوار
وطالبت الكتل الكردستانيه في البرلمان
العراقي بتزويد بغداد بانظمه للدفاع الجوي
للتصدي للهجامات الجويه والصاروخيه
الايرانيه كما طلبت ايضا في بيان لها
الامم المتحده باتخادي موقف قويا وحاسما
ضد الانتهاكات الايرانيه والتركيه للحدود
العراقيه ودعت الكتل الكردستانيه الحكومه
الى اتخاذ موقف جديه لايقاف هجمات ايران
وتركيا ومناقشه ذلك الملف في جلسه خاصه
للبرلمان غدا الثلاثاء
في داخل الايرانيه ارتفعت اعداد الضحايا
المحتاجين الى ما لا يقل عن
متظاهرا بينهم 60 طفلا وقاصرا على الاقل
خلال 10 اسابيع من هذه الاحتجاجات التي
اشعلتها مقتل او اشعلها مقتل الشابه
الكرديه مساء ميمي وعلى ذكر الاكراد
والقوميات الاخرى في ايران صعد النظام
الايراني من عملياته ضد مدن كرديه واذريه
وبلوشيه في اطار حمله القمع لاخماد
المظاهرات واظهرت تسجيلات فيديو اطلاق نار
كثيف في مدينتين مهاباد وبركان بجانب
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه وذلك بعد ما ارسل
الحارس الثوري تعزيزات الامنيه الى مدينه
مهاباد كما امتدت انتهاكات الحرس الثوري
الى الجار الى العراق تجدد القسم
الصاروخيه على عده نقاط داخل اقليم
كردستان العراق
تحججت في طهران بانها مواقع المسلحين
اكراد معارضين للنظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
اذا الاكراد في ايران وحتى القوميات
والاقليات الاخرى في ايران يشكلون دائما
الحلقه الضعيفه التي يمكن ضربها دون عواقب
في خضم هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره ولان
صاحبه شراره الاحتجاجات مهسا امينه كانت
كرديه فقد شهدت فقذ مسقط راس الشابه نقطه
انطلاق المظاهرات التي امتدت الى اكثر من
26 مدينه ومحافظه ايرانيه بينها العاصمه
طهران وفيما يبدو وكانه انتقام تركز قوات
الامن والعسكر المتمثله بالباسيجي والحرس
الثوري على المدن الكرديه في قمع
الاحتجاجات من استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله
وعمليات الاعتقال واختطاف المحتاجين وتبدو
الصوره قاتمه لاكراد ايران بالمقارنه مع
الاكراد في دول اخرى في الشرق الاوسط
كقرانهم في تركيا حيث يشاركون في البرلمان
وفي سوريا يتمتعون داره ذاتيه بحكم الامر
الواقع تحديدا في شمال شرق البلاد ولديهم
ايضا حكم ذكي في اقليم كردستان العراق
ويصنف الاكراد في ايران وغيرهم من
القوميات ايضا كمواطنين درجه ثانيه يحرمون
من ابسط حقوقهم وتكتم اصواتهم ويهمشون
اقتصاديا ايضا يتعرضون لخناق امنيا شديد
يكاد يجعلهم منعزلين عن بقيه المحافظات
الايرانيه نتيجه هذا القمع لجئت العديد من
الاحزاب الكرديه سواء المسلحه او السياسيه
المعارضه لطهران الى اقليم كردستان العراق
وبنوا هناك مواقع ومقرات لهم وفقا لتفاهم
حصل بين حكومه الاقليم وهذه الاحزاب يسمح
لها بالبقاء كل ذلك مقابل شرط اساسي هو
عدم انخراطها في اي عمل عسكري لتفادي
زعزعت علاقه الاقليم مع ايران وهو ما يمنع
على ما يبدو تلك حساب الكرديه من الرد على
القذف الايراني لمواقعها داخل العراق
والحاصل منذ ايام اجتمعت كل من المانيا
والولايات المتحده على صب اهتمامها على
احتجاجات ايران
حيث قال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الالمانيه ان
برلين تتفقوا مع واشنطن على تحويل التركيز
بشان الاتفاق النووي الى قمع المحتجين في
طهران وسبل دعمهم بمواجهه العنف مضيفا
انهم يمارسون ضغوط على النظام الايراني
لايقاف حمله قمع المتظاهرين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وانتقدت الممثله
انجلينا جولي قتل اطفال ايرانيين داخل
اقماع سلطات طهران للاحتجاجات التي تشهدها
المحافظات والمدن الايرانيه منذ سبتمبر
الماضي ونشرت جوليا على صفحتها على
انستغرام صوراطفال ومراهقين قتلوا على
ايدي عناصر الامن الايراني مشدده على ان
الاطفال لهم الحق في التمتع بالحمايه في
مواجهه الخطر واضافت الممثله الامريكيه
انا للاطفال الحق في الحمايه من اي نوع من
الاذى لديهم ايضا الحق في ان يكون لهم صوت
فقط قوليها
وامتنع لاعبوا منتخب ايران عن ترديد
النشيد الوطني قبل مباراههم الافتتاحيه في
كاس العالم لكره القدم امام انجلترا اليوم
الاثنين في اشاره دعم واضحه للاحتجاجات في
بلادهم وصمت كل عناصر التشكيله الاساسيه
لايران اثناء عزف النشيد الوطني في ستاد
خليفه الدولي في الدوحه وعلى المدرجات رفع
بعض المشجعين الايرانيين الشعارات تناصر
الاحتجاجات في بلادهم وتدعوا للحريه
والمراه
وفي سياق متصلا بوادر عمليه عسكريه بريه
جديده قد ينفذها الجيش التركي ضد الاكراد
تحديدا في سوريا والعراق بعد سلسله
الغارات الجويه قبل يومين بينما تجدد
القصف التركي اليوم على مواقع قصد الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان المحا الى ان
العمليه عمليه المخلب السيف لا تقتصر على
العمليات الجويه فقط في اشاره
لمناقشات ستجرى بشان مشاركه قوات بريه
لضمان حدود بلاده من الارهاب وفقه قوله
لكن هناك من يرى ان رئيس التركي يريد من
هذه العمليات العسكريه ضد الاكراد كورا قد
ضغط ضمن حلمه الصراع السياسي الداخليه
التركي قبيل الانتخابات المقرره في يونيو
من العامل المقبل وفقا لمراقبين واحزاب
تركيا معارضه خصوصا وان حزب الرئيس
اردوغان يعاني انخفاضا في الشعبيه والذي
ياتي لاول مره منذ تسلمه للسلطه خلف تحالف
المعارضه بنحو عشر نقاط وفق استطلاعات
الراي وهنا يبدو ان الاكراد قد يشكلوا
اداه لترجيح الكفه لاحد الطرفين اذن هذه
العمليه البريه التي يلمح لها الرئيس
التركي لن تتم الا بموافقه طرفين هما
الولايات المتحده وروسيا التاني تملكان
قواعد عسكريه في شمال شرق سوريا اي في
المناطق الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه
والجانبان اكد في اكثر من مناسبه ان هما
تعرضان اي اجتياح تركي جديد للمناطق
الكرديه وقد يقتصر التصريح الامريكيه
الروسي على السماح لانقره ربما بشن هجمات
محدوده عبر عبر المسيارات وضربه مواقع
معينه دون التوسع في تلك العمليات وفقا
لمصادر كرديه
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الداخليه التركي مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه اخرين في هجوم صاروخي مصدرهم
مناطق المسلحين الاكراد استهدف بلده
كركميش في غازي عنتاب بالقرب من الحدود مع
سوريا واوضح حاكم محافظه غازي عن تاب
داوود غول عبر تويتر انا القوات التركيه
اطلقت خمسه قبائل صواريخ باتجاه وسط
قرقامش نتج عنها مقتل مواطنين واصابه سته
اخرين بجروح خطيره
وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من اربيل
جليل اسد اسيديا كاتب الايراني الكردي عبر
الهاتف لنتحدث عن الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
التي يعني كان لدينا عرض حولها منذ قليل
اهلا بك سيد جليل يعني هذه الاحتجاجات
مستمره اذا منذ اشهر
وهناك ملاحظات تسجل عليها بانها تستهدف
الاقليات هناك يعني تكثيف بالعنف
وبالاسلحه المستخدمه ضد الاكراد والبلوش
الثاني تقيمك لهذا التباين بطاعات القوى
الامنيه الايرانيه مع
المحتاجين همم حسب القوميات التي ينتمون
اليها
اهلا بكم انا معارض كردي ليس معارض ايراني
بالحقيقه
الحكومه الايرانيه كما تعرفون كلكم كما
تعرفون العام لها السياسه التهابيه
والقمعيه امام الشعوب الايرانيه خاصه شعب
الكردي كما تشوفون في هذه الايام
الحكومه الايرانيه قاموا بالحقيقه
بالمجزره الكامل في مليون الكرديه
احد مدن محافظه
وكان واخر المدن الكرديه وهذا يعني احنا
نقدر نقول الامل الذي قام به الحكومه
الايرانيه هو العباده الجماعيه للشعب
الكردي والشعب البريدي والشعوب الاخرى
وايران وهذا من الزمن ليس اليوم اليوم
التالي السياسات كل السياسات الايرانيه في
مكان المتحده السياسه المواطنين الكردي
والمواطنين الشعوب الاخرى الايرانيه ليس
المواطنين الايراني هم يشوف انهم كانهم
كانهم عوامل البلبشه وهما يتصورون
بالحقيقه ان الشعوب الايرانيه هما عامل
الثوره وحامل الانقلاب هسه في مدينه في
مديون الايرانيه وهل شيء صحيح يتعسى من
الزمن السياسات الاقتصاديه والسياسات
الثقافيه والسياسات العسكريه وكل جوانب
الحياه الذي يعيش فيه شعوب الايرانيه كان
مجتهده من قبل الحكومه الايرانيه وقاموا
بهذا الجماهير والمجزره بالتهران بدون
الاخرى هم يتلقون يتلقات ملونه
خاصه همم البارحه واليوم
وثلاثه ايام راح يمر على اطلاق التلقاه
الرسميه بدوشكا هما هم يستفيدون من
الدبابات في الشوارع الدوران
في شوارع المهارات وهذا المشهود لكل
العالم هذه
لازم يتدخل الامم المتحده لازم يتخدل
القوه القدره في الدنيا اذا هم يهتفون
لشعار الديموغرافيه والحقوق الانسانيه
يشوفون الحقوق الانسان في مدن الكليه
يجاوب الناريه
اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن بما يخص الضربات
الايرانيه همم على الاحزاب التي تستهدف
فعليا الاحزاب الكرديه بكردستان حتى الان
لا ردود عسكريه وذلك بسبب الاتفاق بين هذه
الاحزاب وهمم حكومه كردستان همم العراق
الى اين يمكن ان تتجه الامور هل يمكن ان
نشهد يعني مثل دخول او اجتياح للقوات
الايرانيه على الحدود البريه بين العراق
بين كردستان وايضا همم ايران
هناك مسالتين هناك مساله لازم نقولها
المساله الاولى الايرانيون يريدون ان
يحاولون
للاشكلاتهم الى دول الجوار ليس فقط
كردستان صحيح هناك كردستان اي
يه شوكه في عيوننا للحكومه الايرانيه لانه
هما في كل الزمان وفي كل المناسبات وفي كل
المكان يريدون يح
اول حكومه الاقليم في كردستان
الاقتصاديه ضربات العسكريه
هم صابون مدينه اربيل بادله بادله ان ال
مساعد النسائي في باربيل لكن احنا كنا
نعرف ان المصادر في طهران احنا نعرف ان
المصادر الاسرائيلي ينفجر ال ال
المكان القنبله الذريه الايرانيين نحن
ندري ان المساعده الاسرائيليه همم بيده
بعض من
الفوري الايرانيه وحتى نسمع
الديسك الايراني
عبر الحدود باختصار لو سمحت
اذا ساكت العالم واذا سكت الدول المنطقيه
ممكن يشتغل ايران الحدود البريه لاقليم
كردستان كما شفنا الحكومه الايرانيه اذا
اكل صمت هناك ويمكن هذه الاصابه يمكن
بقيام باي مذهله باي لقوارد الدوليه من
الامم المتحده واحنا الناس نشرب نشوف ون-
نعلم ان الطبيعه الحكومه الايرانيه الجمله
المائيه في ايران
يعملون كل شيء في سبيل الحكومه
نعم ان يتصور اذا وهذه صامت بقى في العالم
وفي دول المنطقه الحكومه الايرانيه
بامكانه ان يشتائها الحدود الحريه
لكردستان الاخرى
اذن الكاتب الكردي شكرا جزيلا لك حدثنا من
اربيل
[موسيقى]
نفى وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان نفى بشكل قاطع التقارير
التي تفيد بان المملكه تناقش زياده انتاج
النفط بمقدار 500 الف بر من يوميا واكد
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان ان خفض
الانتاج الحلي بمقدار مليوني برميل يوميا
مستمر حتى نهايه عام 2023 قال وزير الطاقه
السعوديه انه من المعروف انه
تبحث اي قرارات قبل اجتماعاتها واشار الى
الاستعداد للتداخليه اجراءات اخرى لخفض
الانتاج للموازنه بين العرب
والطلب عند الحاجه
التاسعه مستمره ونتابع بعد قليل
الصحه العالميه تحذر من شتاء يهدد حياه
الملايين في اوكرانيا وازي لينزكي يدعو
لحمايه المحطات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
والتزامنا مع اندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه
بالجهه الشرقيه خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره
حذرت الصحه العالميه من شتاء يهدد حياه
الملايين في اوكرانيا فيما يواصل الجيش
الاوكراني تقدمه للاستعاده لوكا من القوات
الروسيه حيث تم احراز تقدم الحوض وفق ما
اعلنت عنه الدفاع الاوكرانيه كما تشهد
دونتسك اعنف المعارك حيث قامت القوات
الروسيه بقص في مواقع اوكرانيه على الخطوط
الاماميه بالمدفعيه كما قامت القوات
الاوكرانيه بقصف محطه نفطيه في مدينه
وضرب الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه بالقضاء في
الصواريخ وفي محور كوبيان صدى الجيش
الروسي هجوما اوكرانيا قتل فيها 20 جنديا
وتم تدمير ثلاثه مركبات عسكريه كما تم
تسجيل سقوط 10 افعل المحطه النوويه في
سبوليسيا ما اعلنت عنه سلطات ذا بوريتشا
الانفصاليه
دوره دعا رئيس الاوكراني ان تو الى ضمان
حمايه المحطات النوويه الاوكرانيه من
التخريب الروسي وفقه تعبيره
هي معركه اكثر صرامه سيواجهها الجيش
الاوكراني في الشرق والهدف تحقيق مكاسب
اضافيه حيث اكدت صحيفه وستا جونيا لان
الانتصار الميداني الذي حققه الجيش
الاوكراني في خرسون غير من الديناميكيات
المتبعه في مسار المعركه في اشاره الى ان
التقدم الاوكراني الاخير في خرسون سيسمح
للجيش الاوكراني من استهداف في خطوط
الامداد الروسيه التي تصل الى شبه جزيره
القرم والتي استولت عليها موسكو من
اوكرانيا في عام 2014 بينما لا تزال روسيا
تعاني من نقص في الافراد ومشاكل في
القياده وسيكون الجيش الاوكراني مجبرا على
تحقيق مكاسب ميدانيه وتنفيذ هجمات مضاده
وانشاء خطوط دفاعيه في دوم بس بعد ان تمكن
من استعادته
[موسيقى]
اصبحوا متوحشين بين الحين والاخر لكن
مدفعيتنا لا تسمح لهم بالتقاط انفاسهم في
مثل هذه اللحظات لدينا
في الكتيبه لذلك نقوم بالاستطلاع اثناء
القصف ونحدد المواقع التي يطلقون النار
منها
[موسيقى]
دمرت القوات المسلحه الروسيه في منطقه
خرسون مجموعه التخريبي والاستطلاع التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه اثناء محاولتها
العبور بالقارب الى الضفه اليسرى لنهر
النبوي واوضح الممثل الرسمي لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الفريق ايجور كوناشينكوف انه تم
تدمير مجموعه التخريب والاستطلاع التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في منطقه نيبرو
فاسكي بمنطقه خرسون اثناء محاولتها العبور
بالقارب الى الضفه اليسرى لنهر بالاضافه
الى تدمير مستودع الاسلحه والمعده
العسكريه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
منطقه راماتوس في جمهوريه دونالدز الشعبيه
دعت بعثه الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان في
اوكرانيا كافر الى التحقيق في فيديو نشر
مؤخرا يظهر او يظهر فيه اعدام لاسرى روسيا
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مؤخرا ان
قواتك اعدمت اكثر من 10 اسرع حرب من
الجنود الروسي في جريمه صورها جنود
اوكرانيين ونشروها دون اخفاء وجوههم وفقا
للدفاع الروسيه التي شددت على ان الفيديو
والمنشور لهذه المذبح الجماعيه بحق الاسرى
الروس العزل يؤكد طبيعتكاف طبيعه النظام
الوحشي بقياده زنسكي حسب قولهم وهم من
يدافعون همم عنه ويدعمون وفق الوصف الروسي
بدورها نفذ السلطات الاوكرانيه تنفيذ
احكام اعدام بحق الاسره من القوات الروسيه
في ظل الحرب القائمه بين البلدتين
صواريخ روسيه قيمتها تتجاوز مليار يورو
عادت بنتائج مخيبه لي موسكو لتقتصر على
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي لساعه قليله
والسبب الابداع الاوكراني رفقا لتقرير
لصحيفه بوليتكو الامريكيه التطورات
الحاصله في الميدان علمت الاوكرانيين
كيفيه التخلص من العقليه السوفياتيه
المنهكه التي تصعب ايجاد الحلول وقت الحرب
فما تواصل سلسله الهجمات الروسيه المتكرره
على مشاهد الطاقه في اوكرانيا كان الابداع
والارتجال وسيد الموقف في تجاوز ازمه
انقطاع الكهرباء حيث يقوم المهندسون
الاوكرانيون باصلاح الوضع في غضون السعاده
والسعاده الطاقه بعد ضربات الصواريخ
الروسيه اسقاط تصريحات لمسؤول اوكراني
نشرتها صحيفه بوليسيكو فان اوكرانيا تتجه
نحو خلق نظام طاقه يتماشى مع فكره الصمود
في وجه الهجوم الروسي واعتماد استراتيجيه
جديده قائمه على تنسيق الجهودي هلالي
دراسه السيناريوهات المحتمله وايجاد حلول
لها ضمن مخططات اعاده التوحشيح
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا عبر سكايب من دونات رائد
الاغرب مراسل العربيه ومن ميكو لايف حذيفه
عادل مراسل العربيه اهلا بكما رائد بدايه
معك نتحدث عن محور زابور يعني هناك همم
التقادف بالتهامات بين الجانب الاوكراني
والروسي حول من استهدف محطه ما هي اخر
التصريحات وما هي الاضرار اضرار المحطه
راويه مساء الخير بالفعل يعني التبادل
بالاتهامات من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
والجانب الروسي بقصف المحطه النوويه الذي
يمكن ان يسبب كارثه بشريه في المنطقه
ومحيطه المنطقه بالفعل السلطات مقاطعه
زبروجه التابعه لروسيا تقول بان الجيش
الاوكراني ضرب اكثر من 10 قذائف على منشات
متعدده من المحطه النوويه
والمنشئه الخامسه ايضا الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان قد عرض صور فيديو على قناه على
تيليجرام لوقت الضرب لحظه الضرب المنشاه
النوويه بالفعل هناك خطر كبير يهدد
المنطقه هذا من جانب لكن ال- المحور
الاكثر سخونه راويه لو سمحت الوقت يعني
نتحدث عن يسكن معارك ضاريه بالفعل
نعم تفضل
هنا نشهد حضور قوات روسيه باعداد كبيره
وسط المدينه وفي الاسواق وايضا العسكريه
كبيره لابد ان دفعات من التعبئه الجزئيه
التي اعلنت عنها روسيا وصلت الى المنطقه
او ان القوات التي انتقلت الى الضفه
الشماليه في خرسان بدات بالانتقال الى
محور دانيت وهم يحققون حسب السلطات
المحليه هنا تقدم على عده جبهات الجبهه
الجنوبيه منطقه اوبلدار بعد السيطره على
مدينه
بالفعل هناك يعني تقدم
وحضور للقوات التابعه لروسيا في هذا
المحور والمحور الشمالي مدينه
ومعارك وسط المدينه ايضا محيط العاصمه
متبادل ما بين الجيش الاوكراني والجيش
الروسي همم تسقط ص همم امريكيه الصنع على
المنطقه والجيش الروسي ايضا يقصف مدينه
ابريكا المتاخمه ويقول بانه سيطر على
اطراف المدينه التقدم الوحيد للجيش الروسي
في محور دانيت بينما تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه اقتحام مناطق في مقاطعه لوغانس
كان قد سيطر عليها الجيش المصري سابقا وهي
مدينتي سيفردان تقول الدفاع الروسيه
الكبيره
زي فما هي اخر التحديثات الميدانيه حيث
تتواجد انت
في الحقيقه وصلت توا الى مدينه ميكا لايف
في الجنوب الاوكراني هذه المدينه التي
يعني تشهد عمليات قصف مستمره هذه المدينه
هي في خط النار منذ بدايه الحرب بشكل عام
كامل ولايه ميكاويف كانت تقاتل حتى وقت
قريب استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تستعيد
السيطره على كامل الولايه ما عدا شبه
جزيره صغيره جدا هي ما زالت تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه طبعا هي اخر المدن التي تم
استعاده السيطره عليها هنا في ميكا لايف
ميكا لايف تعاني كبقيه المدن الاوكرانيه
من الانقطاعات في الكهرباء عدد كبير من
الاحياء هنا ايضا تعاني من انقطاع في
المياه اخر عمليات القصوى التي تعرضت لها
المدينه كانت بالامس في الساعه الواحده
وحتى الساعه الثالثه بعد ذلك قضت ميكا
لايف ليلى كانت هادئه او كذلك النهار هذا
اليوم كان عادي ان في هذه المدينه لم
تتعرض لقذف ولكن بشكل عام القصف يتواصل في
منطقه خرسون اليوم قتل عدد من المواطنين
وعدد من الجرحى في داخل المدينه في مركز
المدينه وكذلك في بعض القرى في منطقه
خرسانه التي استعادت السيطره عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه حديثا يقول يعني همم
كريم شوك وهو مساعد الرئيس الاوكراني قال
ان الروس قد خرجوا او كما استخدم التعبير
هربوا من منطقه خرسون ولكنهم باشروا بقصف
المدنيين والان والمدينه تحت القصف هذا في
منطقه خرسانه التي ايضا تعاني من وضع
الانسان صعب جدا مثلها مثل ميكا لايف التي
همم يعني تعاني من وضع صعب ايضا انقطاع في
الكهرباء انقطاع في الشبكه انقطاع في
المياه لا يوجد مواد تموينيه كافيه بدات
بعض الولايات في تسيير القوافل اليوم وصلت
اخر قافله من بلطافه خمسه شاحنات من
الغذاء والطعام وايضا من المياه هو بعض
همم
الاشياء الخاصه بالاطفال كحليب الاطفال
وما الى ذلك وصلت اليوم ههه الى منطقه
خرسانه اما بخصوص جبهات القتال فكما تفضل
رائد الجبهه الساخنه هي في دونيسكو وتحاول
القوات الروسيه التقدم في محور الطاقم
وتعدد من القرى والمناطق في منطقه باك
مثلي السيطره والاصول الى هذه المدينه
العامه استراتيجيا اما القوات الاوكرانيه
فهي تتقدم في اسفيت اوف وفي كريم في اتجاه
لغاز وقال سيرجي كيداي انهم الان اصبحوا
قريبين من منطقه الشاص وقال ان القوات
الروسيه اصبحت تطرد المدنيين من القرى في
محيط منطقه ليسي شاسكو وتسيطر على منازلهم
لاسكان القوات الروسيه لمنع تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه والسيطره على محيط هذه المدينه
والتقدم الى داخل المدينه قال في الاستاد
وكذلك في فرجانكو وكذلك في سيفردوس قال في
في جميع هذه المدن الان صوت الجبهه مسموع
للمدنين داخل المدره شكرا
رائد الاخبار من دونسك
على الجانب السياسيه وفي لقاء خاص مع
العربيه صراحه سفير بيلاروسيا في الامارات
ان بلاده حاولت اداره المفاوضات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لكن هناك اطراف ترفض الحواء
[موسيقى]
حاولنا جهدنا وتمكننا من اداره ثلاث جولات
من المفاوضات في مارس الماضي لكن
المفاوضات الان معلقه نحن نعرف قيمه
السلام بعدما تعرضنا له في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه القنوات الدبلوماسيه موجوده لكن
لابد من طرف ان يتحرك
نشره تنام مستمره وفي سياقها بعد قليل
تسريحات جديده متوقعه في تويتر واستقاله
مدراء اقليمين للمنصه الزرقاء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
من تويتر يبدو ان المليار دار الامريكي
الخمس سنين
تماما كما حدث حينما طلب احدهم اعاده حساب
المنظر الامريكي وصاحب النظريات النظريات
المؤامره تحديدا
زلزال التسريحات او عاصفه الاستقالات لا
فرق كلاهما ينظر بكارثه في تويتر فالدخول
من باب الشركه حتما ليس كخروجه
عدو هجران تويتر لم تقتصر على افراد
بعينهم بل ان شركات باسرها حولت مسارتها
الى منصه اخرى بسبب ترنح التطبيق على ايدي
الملياردير الامريكي الى مصر
ثم قال لبقيتهم اما ان تعملوا بتسال غير
مشروط والا فرحل وفعلا غادروا بلا ان
ينذروا وراءهم ليتركوا الطائره الازرق
باجنحه تعتصر الف موظف ما زالوا صامدين
رغم انهم قد يغيرون ارائهم لاحقا فالافلاس
وارد في ظل تراجع الاعلانات التي تمثل 90%
من دخل الشركه امام ماسك الذي يسر على ان
عصفوره حي يرزق ولا قفص سيذبح نشاطه يمطر
المستخدمين بغزاره تغريداته وبين الحين
والاخر يبدو انه يضمنها شيئا من حياته
الخاصه
اخرها حول امكانيه اعاده حساب المنظر
الامريكي وصاحبي نظريات المؤامره اليكس
جونز بشان مذبحه وقعت في مدرسه عام 2012
وراحه ضحيتها 28 طفلا لياتي الجواب صارما
ومستذكرا به مراره فقد ابنه الذي لم
يتجاوز ال 10 اسابيع هذا الغني المصنف
كاحد اثرياء العالم سبق وان صرح ايضا بانه
مشرد بلا منزل يقويه وحياته ليست مطرفه
كما يخير للبعض وبغض النظر الى ان العوده
الى احضان تويتر لم تكن برفع الحظر عن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فحسب
وانما على مغني الراب الشهير كان يوست
الذي سبق والتهمه بمعادته الساميه حينما
ارتدي قميصا كتب عليه حياه البيض مهمه
ليبدو ماسك بشكل او باخر متضامنا معه
ولمن لا يعرف فان الماسك الذي ولد في 28
يونيو عام
1971 في بريتوريا امه كنديه وابوه من جنوب
افريقيا ذو اصول هولنديه وبريطانيه اي انه
ثلاثي الجنسيه اخرها حصوله على الامريكيه
قبل 20 سنه انا منه ترى رعت على حب
القراءه وكان شغوفا باجهزه الحاسوب وتطوير
البرمجيات
لكنه مصاب بمتلازمه احد اضطرابات الطيف
التوحد اسبرجر التي وصفها خبراء الصحه
بانها قد تكون النقطه قوه في انجازاته
وابتكارته ماسك الذي ينوي ان يحلق مع
طائره الازرق بنسخه محدثه يقول فيها وداعا
لتويتر القديم
اسراء الصغير العربيه
في المقابل تستمر عاصفه الاستقالات في
تويتر اخرها اعلن المدير العام لفرع
الشركه في فرنسا دميانفيل الذي غادر من
اصوات التواصل الاجتماعي من دون ان يوضح
ما اذا كان قد استقل من تلقاء نفسه او
ارغم على مغادره المنصه
[موسيقى]
لا حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من الرياض
عبر زوم عبد الله السبع المحرر التقني في
صحيفه عربيه اهلا بك معنا عبد الله يعني
لم يكتفي اذا الماسك بموجات التسريحه
الماضيه هناك موجات مرتقبه جديده لتسريح
الموظفين يعني نود ان نفهم ما اسباب هذه
التسريحات هل هي نتيجه خطه هيكليه لتغيير
او تطوير التويتر ام انه هناك اسباب ربما
ماليه
وخاصه ان هناك حديث عن الشبح الافلاس
وبانه يحيط بتويتر
لازم نعرف موضوع ان اسباب
الاقالات الموظفين واستبعادهم
وباستعادهم من الشركه لازم نعرف معلومه ان
احد اسبابها قرارات الشركه السابقه يعني
في الفتره الماضيه
ظهر رئيس التنبيه للشركه السابق وتكلم ان
احد يعتذر للموظفين الذي تم اقالتهم بسبب
منا احد اسباب هذا الموضوع عدد الموظفين
الشركه الكبر بشكل جدا كبير هم ما كانوا
متصورينها ايضا لازم نعرف معلومه ان
الجميع منصات التواصل اجتماعيه قلت
مدخلاتها من الاعلانات بسبب قوانين
الخصوصيه الجديده اللي موجوده في اغلب
حرير الاجهزه فضل بدايه السنه او من نهايه
السنه الماضيه اطلقت قوانين خصوصيه جديده
تساعد المستخدمين في حفاظ خصوصيتهم هو هذا
ما اثر على جوده الاعلانات في جميع منصات
التواصل اجتماعيه وقلل من مدخولات
الاعلانات في جميع منصات التواصل
الاجتماعيه بجانب شيء اخر وهي الازمات
الماليه التي تمر فيها كل الشركات خلال
فتره الماضيه وانخفاض الاعلانات بشكل جدا
كبير خلال اشهر الماضيه بسبب الازمه
العالميه المختلفه لكلنا عارفينه ونسمع
عنها فلذلك كل الشغلات هذه ادت الى عمليات
اقالات مختلفه بالشركه خلال فتره الماضيه
مما ساهم في انخفاض اعداد المستخدمين
ولازم نعرف معلومه انه مو فقط تويتر اقالت
موظفينها انما فيسبوك اقالت اكثر
بريء من انه هو تقصد ومنذ لامه همم اداره
تويتر ان يسرح موظفين هذا الذي افهم من
كلامه
بريء لكن هو صاحب شركه وقدام معطيات معينه
واي اكيد ايضا شركه تحتاج دماء جديده
لتنفيذ الرؤى اللي موجوده عندهم لازم نعرف
معلومه تويتر واحد من اقدم مناصات التواصل
الاجتماعيه لكن حتى الان هو ما وصلت
تقريبا الى مليار مستخدم فعال زي ما وصلوا
ولا انستغرام زي ما وصل ولا فيسبوك زي ما
وصلنا تك توك اللي طلع بعد تويتر لذلك
وجود دماء جديده للشركه اكيد هذا من صالح
شركه لانهم همم حتى الان يدورون في دوامه
وحيده همم نفسها فاحتياج الى دماء جديده
اكيد ممكن يحدث
ماذا عن ابعاد او استقاله كبار همم او
مدراء فرعين مثل همم مدير العام للشركه
بفرنسا دميان يعني
هي اا الشخصيات الكبرى كان لها دور بنجاح
تطبيق تويتر لماذا تستقيل او تقال
ممكن ما اعجبتهم سياسه جديده ليتبعها
الرئيس التنفيذي هذه احد الامور وقد
يكونون انهم قالوا لازم نعرف معلومه ان
ااه في حاله يعني يقدر نقول عدم رضا عن
اداء جميع الموظفين داخل الشركه فلذلك انا
جاي بدماء جديده بافكار جديده ممكن ما تم
التوافق ما بين الموظفين همم وما بين رؤيا
رؤيه الشركه الجديده وهذا يحصل في اي شركه
موجوده حول العالم اذا كانت قادمه برؤيه
جديده الاداره العليا جديده وفكر جديد
دائما ما تحصل هناك ايقالات اما بين
الرؤساء التنفيذيين او المدراء التنفيذيه
لانه ممكن ما تكون رؤيه الشركه معجبه فيها
فاذا انا غير معجب بروايه الشركه الجديده
اكيد اني ما راح اكون متواجد حتى لو
تطبقها
جديده هناك من يتحدث او نظريات تقول بانه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تمر الان بازمه
منتصف العمر ويتم ربط ذلك بخسائر بتكون
بتكون وكل العملات الرقميه هل توافق بانه
همم يمكن همم اسهم هذه مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ان- تنزل الى الاسفل باختصار لو
سمحت
سناب شات على سبيل المثال لم يحقق ارباح
الا في ربع واحد من بدايته فيسبوك قاعد
تعاني من خسائر جدا كبيره بسبب مغامرات في
عالم الميته فيرست
والاعلانات منخفضه وقوانين الخصوصيه ادت
وساهمت بشكل جدا كبير في انخفاض داخل
الصوت
[موسيقى]
في اوروبا السباق على تامين الغاز من اجل
الفصول الشتاء المستقبليه يشتد ومساعي
ابرام صفقات الغاز الطبيعي المسال مع
الشركات الامريكيه متواصله فما تزايد
المخاوف بشان امن الطاقه يسعى الكثير من
الاوروبيين للحصول على الغاز لمده خمس الى
عشر سنوات وفقه صحيفه وسط رجل التي اشارت
لوجود مخاوف كبيره
والحكومات الاوروبيه الذين يترددون في
توقيع عقود توريد طويله الاجر والاكتفاء
بوضع اهداف طموحه من اجل استهلاك الوقود
الاحفوري بشكل كبير وفقا مراقبين فمخزون
الغاز في الاتحاد الاوروبي ممتلئ بنسبه
95% وهو ما سيجنب القاره كارثه طاقه كانت
وشيكا مع اقتراف فصل الشتاء لكن من
المتوقع ان يصبح شراء الغاز لفصول الشتاء
القادمه اكثر صعوبه بالنسبه للدول
الاوروبيه بعد ان لا معظمها عن الامدادات
الروسيه والتزايد المنافسه العالميه على
الغاز الطبيعي المثال فالكثير من الشركات
الالمانيه تحديدا التي تعتبر وتعتبر محرك
التصنيع الاوروبي بعدت قلقه بشان امتلاك
طاقه كافيه للجزء الاخير من هذا العقد حيث
قامت باجراء محادثات مع مصدرين غاز
الطبيعي لمسال الامريكيين حول صفقات
امدادات الغاز المحتمله التي يمكن ان تبدا
بعد منتصف العقد كما اقترح مسؤول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تشكيله مجموعه من الشركات
الاوروبيه لتنسيق محادثات صفقه الغاز
وشراء المشترك للوقودي في المرحله المقبله
واشارت الحكومه البريطانيه الا انها تعمل
مع الموردين المحليين والدولين لاستكشاف
العقود التي يمكن ان تزيد من امن امدادات
الطاقه غير ان المشاكل الرئيسيه مشاهدينا
التي يمكن ان تعرقل مسار نجاح هذه الصفقات
هي سياسه التسعير والاهداف المناخيه اذا
يقول بعض المراقبين انها قد تعرقل الاهداف
المناخيه الهادفه الى خفض انبعاثات غازات
الاحتباس الحراري
[موسيقى]
ماذا الرئيس الامريكي
قبل لقائه الافتتاح امام ويلز في اطار
مباريات المجموعه الثانيه لكاس العالم حيث
اجرى بيضا اتصالا بالفريق لتحفيزه مع
انطلاق المنافسات وطالب المدير الفني
بوضعه في التشكيلات الاساسيه
انا
[موسيقى]
في زلزال ضرب جزيره جاوا العاصمه
الاندونيسيا جاكرتا وبحسب مسؤول حكومي قال
ان الزلزال بلغت شدته 5.6 درجه على مقياس
اخضر
[موسيقى]
نشره المساء مع العناوين
بغداد تنجدوا بالعجمات الايرانيه والتركيه
على اقليم كردستان وترفض تصفيه الحسابات
على ارضها
وزير الطاقه
بمقدار 500000 برميل يوميا ويؤكد استمرار
التخفيض حتى 2023
صدى الاحتجاجات يصل الى المونديال لاعبوا
المنتخب الايراني يرفضون ترديد اناشيد
بلادهم ويتلقون سته اهداف من انجلترا
في اندونيسيا ارتفاعه وحصيله الزلزال الى
162 قتيلانا ومخاوف من وجود العشرات تحت
الانقاذ